this episode is brought to you by
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
[Music]
from the Lifestyle brand for guys with a
favorite cinematographer and the
directing Duo of the humping guy from
the turndown for What video and the
sketchy librarian comes a film that
combines Hollywood's last two genres
Rick and Morty and heartfelt stories
about dysfunctional Asian families oh
identity oh look out Morty hot dog
fingers everything everywhere all at
once after Coda and Green books wins had
you questioning your faith in the Oscars
One winner comes along and totally
redeems the academy that's how it works
right in this award season darling they
got its cast some overdue recognition
and was a breakthrough in representation
for both Asians and Giants in the year's
best picture
[Music]
Forrest Gump could never you love to
watch Michelle yo heroically jump all
over the screen
foreign
to that residual love because her
character Evelyn is super mean Joy
a bad listener Evelyn
yes
and vaguely anti-semiticism
when the Multiverse is threatened by a
evil Bagel she'll heroically jump into
action again to save reality from the
daughter she tortured to the point of
insanity is there a timeline where she
doesn't suck
I have something to say to you
you are getting fat
nope
Temple of Doom and Goonies veteran kihi
Quan returns as a Plucky sidekick with
lots of offbeat inventions at his
disposal it's like he never left and
Stephanie Shu co-stars as their daughter
Joy a character whose complex Journey
takes her to the edge of Madness and
back playing both a teenager struggling
to connect with her mom and an
omnipotent nihilist seeking to destroy
the universe so of course she lost the
Oscar to Jamie Lee Curtis as a mean lady
with a funny voice Mrs way hello let's
just pretend this was a makeup for True
Lies
blast off for a blend of high-flying
action that breaks all the rules of
reality
then settle in for Endless explanations
about how the new rules of this reality
this is your universe
the algorithms that calculates what's
statistically improperable action that
will place you in a Universe on the edge
of your local custom you underestimate
how the smallest decision can compound
to significant differences over a
lifetime I'm not husband and he's not
the one you know the alpha first you
discover the way to temporarily link
your Consciousness to another version of
yourself accessing all of the memories
the skills great got it but once that's
all clear make way for oh hang on
there's more you're mine it's like a
clay pot holding water every jump opens
another crack if you fall for The
Temptations you invite contradiction
chaos but once that's shut up rocks but
once that's all clear Make Way for some
genuinely heartfelt moments that will
bring tears to your googly eyes don't
call your license
foreign
and comedy that reads like an audition
tape for Untitled phase six Marvel movie
[Music]
you know that's where this is going
right the Daniel's already crushed their
Harry Potter reboot
so strap on that fanny pack and get
ready for the best exploration of the
Multiverse yet mainly because Marvel's
fumbled the bag so hard sure most of it
takes place in the same building your
infinite cells are just you with a
different career and it's full of the
same remember that movie moments that
make up most of Pop Culture now
but you know what the acting is great it
looks amazing and the message is so
important to hear right now don't do
your taxes they can't make you and if
they try you can beat them up or seduce
them with your hands that's my plan at
least
story Tomorrow Never dries the key to
this movie Freaky foreplay King Hong
rocket powered Joy to the worlds now
you're all dead Becky with the bad hair
the power of the dog when the movie you
wrote and directed is an elaborate
excuse to live out your Michelle yo
dominatrix fetish and Biff with that's
the stage name he chose Biff with
crazy switched Asians
are they supposed to be all different
versions of Evelyn or just the Darkest
Timeline where she's an nft
e-e-a-a-o was awesome but how about BTN
in our latest episode of by the Numbers
we track down John Wick's headshot
percentage all weapons used and the
toughest opponent he's had to face click
the thumbnail on the right to watch now
this episode was brought to you by
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
only in theaters March 31st
in another life I would have loved doing
laundry and taxes with you I'm sorry no
there's a mistake morbius you guys won
best picture